really the big breakthrough came for me
with a very powerful mushroom journey on
October 20th 2018 which very much
launched me and and it's been it's been
quite a journey since then yeah it's
been amazing since then in the six
months later we passed the criminate
sure now we're in 100 cities 30 states 5
countries in terms of members of this
movement we have about another half a
dozen cities passing the resolution so
it's been one hell of a roller coaster
that really for me germinated in that
one mushroom journey because of the
level of clarity it gave me about my own
childhood trauma like really how to heal
from that but after that mushroom
journey I it was very challenging for me
to understand what happened to my brain
and I could suddenly see the world from
so many different perspectives that I
could certainly be having these
conversations with myself that were far
more enlightened and I was able to have
before the mushroom so the resolution is
beautiful it's so simple it simply says
in company multiple we're asses and
therefore be it resolved that our
relationship to entheogenic plants and
fungi should be the same as our
relationship to Tomatoes
same as our relationship to an orange
orange tree two herbs we want to grow in
our garden that there is nothing
fundamentally different between our
religions there should not be anything
fundamentally different than a
relationship to antigenic plants and
fungi consciousness healing plants and
an orange that it's decriminalized
there's no controls on how much you grow
I can share it with friends our goal at
the idea would be to get all plants and
fungi removed from schedule I know
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sock young we are on
site at the beautiful new West summit
the cannabis tech conference we are now
going to be talking with Carlos plus Ola
hi Carlos I thanks so much for coming on
our show really appreciate it thank you
for inviting me so pumped for this
conversation carlos is the co-founder of
decriminalized nature oakland Carlos
let's start things off by talking about
your journey who are you how you even
got interested in this space
yeah X has been quite a journey started
somewhere around the age of 10 but only
held some minor details the journey
starts with me trying to find my my
clarity about what this world is and
what it means and try to heal from some
childhood trauma
it takes me through my going to college
and getting my degree in environmental
science living amongst the Oshawa
community and the rainforest at the age
of 23 and pursuit of the sacred and then
then comes life and family and and I get
a beautiful wife children I'm living the
day-to-day life of making money and and
all of that and then then I have this
particular severe trauma hit with my
mother passing and the extended family
kind of begins to disintegrate with all
of that and relationships disintegrate
and so I went through this healing
process and found my way to meditation
yoga and and then but really the big
breakthrough came for me with a very
powerful mushroom journey on October
20th 2018 which pretty much launched me
and and it's been it's been quite a
journey since then yeah it's been
amazing since then and then six months
later we passed the Crim Nature now
we're in 100 cities 30 states five
countries in terms of members of this
movement we have about another half
dozen cities passing the resolution so
it's been one hell of a roller coaster
that really for me germinated in that
one
mushroom journey because of the level of
clarity it gave me about my own
childhood trauma and really how to heal
from that so that's that's it in that
gel
whoa let's let's also go to the if we if
we could go all the way back to it did
the childhood what was what was going on
I'm free growing up that was making it
difficult sure yeah no I'm the child of
immigrant parents my father himself was
left when he was very young didn't know
how to really be a father so very soon
after I was born he kind of bailed and
so mom was left to raise her kids by
herself
and here I'm us three kids she had about
twenty bucks in her pocket we took a
midnight train literally out of Mexico
and landed in the US with some family we
you know struggled in terms of she
struggled in terms of working long hours
to make money so I was many ways to sort
of raising myself and then soon
thereafter she met a man who was an
alcoholic and that came into the family
we had a you know the the physical abuse
there was alcoholism there was yelling
there was there was a very unsettled
moment and so as a as a being that
really loved peace and love beauty to be
immersed in this really hectic and
violent world sent me searching what's
it all mean so that was sort of me up
until the age of 16 and 17 left me oh Sh
this is bro yeah Aswad was in 20 24
years old 23 years old I live with the
AH spots oh okay this was like in my
early 7 8 9 10 11 12 you were searching
for
for yeah why was i searching so yards
Wow
yeah so the way that came about was
someone told me that someone in my
family this is kind of a Genesis this is
the sparked the seed if you will of my
own searching in the world at the age of
around eight or nine someone told me
that someone of my family died right and
so then I said well what happens when
they die where did they go and they said
well they go to heaven where they live
forever when they was like okay and then
I went to bed and I'm I okay forever try
to imagine what that is I'm like eight
years old right so then I started
obsessing with what forever meant and it
really became from the age of eight
until 23 I obsessed about it and I
couldn't figure it out so it sort of
became this fascination with zero and
the infinite zero being the end and
nothingness and then the infinite of
course is where does forever go so but
that while it was traumatic it also
helped push me through a lot of the
trauma because from that state of
realizing there's something far more you
know esoteric than us being punched in
the head is a pretty minor thing right
so it allowed me to sort of rise above
the trauma so when I was ready to leave
home at 17 18 I got into biology and
anthropology which were natural for me
because I wanted to understand this
planet life humans what all this was so
that was my first sort of venture into
what I really began a pursuit of beauty
and sacred Wow alright so I really
appreciated how you were like walking us
through this divine search that you
embarked on it's just a young little lad
and also just having something that
could be like an anchor for you like
this this forever
throughout that process and then what
was it you know when you're 23 hush what
you said though I SWAT hush what that's
why they're the original headhunters in
the rainforest that we read about that
we see in movies they're also known as
the he bottle and they live in the
Amazon rainforest in Ecuador in Colombia
northern Colombia so the way that came
about is I'm a biology major at UCLA my
professor dr. Robert Bailey tells the
story about how he left Wall Street
after a couple 10-15 years of success
feeling empty and so he went to live in
the rainforest with tribe in the in the
Brazilian rainforest and I was just
fascinated so I said I have to do that
so how do I do that
and he said well there's this
husband-and-wife team out of Santa
Barbara that are going down there PhD
students that are finishing up some
research and I say okay I need to go so
you say let me put you in contact with
them I called them they told me well if
you really want to go learn how to do
health studies particularly using
calipers that we could do health studies
based on the indigenous folks becoming
sedentary because oil companies using
their labor for search of oil and so I
did that I showed up and next thing you
know I'm on a dual plane dual engine
plane heading into the rainforest it was
an hour in off the of the nearest city
which is Puyo and we're flying in and
hour later we're coming on this little
landing strip I in the middle of the
rainforest I'm thinking what the hell
did I just do right and it's not just
any group these are the famous
headhunters the he model right and but
it was absolutely a tremendous
experience they were welcoming they were
loving and but because they were
sedentary after you know typically they
were nomadic they didn't particularly
share food because their meat resources
were being depleted right I was one of
the effects that was why we went to
study it and so the effect of all of
that was they didn't share their meat
much so I ended up losing 30 pounds
because I wasn't a very
hunter-gatherer turns out my little kid
from East San Jose wasn't very good
together it turns out but anyway I
survived I made it it was beautiful and
I had an opportunity to do ayahuasca
there within a true shamanistic
experimental experience and in a circle
with the village villagers so it was a
very beautiful experience I found the
sacred there by the way tell you more
about finding oh well they live
connected to the land they live
connected to each other everything is
sacred right it's the they know the
plants for their medicine they know the
plants for their food they see their
ancestors in the plants to see their
ancestors in each other in the actions
that they do everything has meaning
right and that's the sacred right it's
sort of one of the most challenging
things was coming back into Western
civilization at the time because now I
had found the sacred and I'm going back
to the land that had not been
particularly kind to me so I experienced
the emptiness that that we experienced
sometimes in the West that leads us to
the use of opiates and depressions and
all those things but really at that
point it really I engaged in trying to
figure out how to create social change
for preservation of the planet social
justice so about a month later I found
myself at the Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies and so now
from the rain forest I'm walking the
halls of Yale so it was pretty pretty
trippy experience from losing 30 pounds
of poor inability to hunt and gather
your own back in the halls of the
cafeteria Ivy League but now and that
was the extreme my it's the Ivy League
we're talking about people with
tremendous privilege to people who are
struggling just to survive and preserve
their ways so it was
big dichotomy of worldviews but so I
absorbed it all just to try to expand my
own worldview that's very awakening to
get those stark dichotomies very
awakening yeah yeah and and so from
there a lot of my peers we had a
decision to make my peers and I about
what we would do with our future so for
me I chose to follow the path of love
which was really how do I step forward
into the world in a way where I'm coming
at it from the heart and so I did
organizing with a pastor there who was
working with formerly incarcerated and
then I from there I went into community
organizing worked with acorn I did
social justice organizing environmental
justice organizing and then from from
there I went into political organizing
running campaigns working in government
all the wild is learning the tools of
creating change and and then I went into
business because if you can't figure out
the capitalist model then you really
can't function in this world so for the
last 15 years I've been learning
financial modeling and the world of
capitalism so when that day came October
20th 2018 and I had that kind of big
moment of clarity about my own path and
where I was it was pretty national next
step to take all those tools and then
put him to work to push for the
decolonization of the very thing that
sort of liberated my own consciousness
there's a way of saying thank you
okay so we have this process that you
had of working on social justice and
environmental causes and just cause us
for further catalyzing awakening and
other people over time and you're
picking up strategies along the way and
you wanted to implement that for
specifically D criminal so yeah how did
the idea seed for decriminalize I'll
give you my my path of course everyone
who was at the table had their own path
to the table but after that mushroom
journey I it was very challenging for me
to understand what happened to my brain
that I could suddenly see the world from
so many different perspectives that I
could certainly be having these
conversations with myself that were far
more enlightened than I was able to have
before the mushrooms and it confused me
in many ways so I went in search of
community and this is now we're I wasyou
experience with curandero
2 23 24 years old yeah and then the
mushroom experience was just a year ago
a year ago yeah the lesson year ago and
between that was not what was that not
too much well ayahuasca experience
didn't really do much because it was
very light it was very light yeah so all
I did was give me a deeper sense of
sensory experience how you into vision
and hearing that's all it did but you
also had the understanding of the
interconnectedness of the tribal
indigenous lifestyle so so I understood
the sacred from the intellectual
perspective on the cerebral cortex
perspective so to speak the mind that
brain I understood it intellectually
right people say you understand God
intellectually yeah yeah yeah versus the
feeling yeah a very deep knowing
yeah so so that was in between 23 to 50
Wow and so there was still a struggle
and it would manifest in if I was under
high duress if I felt as if I was being
attacked I would go into self-protection
or even counter-attack mode which is
something we see in PTSD something we
see in people who have been abused where
it's about self-protection there's an
immediate place of assuming you're being
attacked and and so I recognized that
I've known that about myself at least
for the last five years due to a lot of
deep meditation okay so you meditation
was a big connecting thread over those
20 years yeah yeah sorry when I was 20
when I'm sorry when I was a 44 45 my
mother passed mmm so about six years ago
my mother passed away and that sort of
reawakened a lot of the childhood trauma
because my sister brother and I were not
prepared to know how to deal with that
level of complexity of trauma and we
didn't have the tools because we weren't
given those tools when we were young and
how do you work through these challenges
right in a way that isn't yelling or
screaming or fighting right because
that's what you're taught that's what we
were taught so so now I'm seeing all of
this disintegrate around me
relationships breaking down people
getting into deep deep depression around
me not knowing how to function in the
world and I'm looking around thinking
what do I do with all this so I started
with myself and said let's try healing
the self first
and as I when did that I went into yoga
then I found shavasana when I found
shavasan I said what is this thing
consciousness I'm suddenly recognizing
there's this other state of being where
you're aware of your own awareness and
and so from there I went deeply into
meditation meditating almost daily daily
for about two years and as I went
through that process I sort of let go of
all of the trauma everything that was
binding me but I still had the reaction
I still was reacting from a place of
self-protection
anxiety when I felt under duress so I
realized that there was something in my
brain that wasn't in under my control
even with meditation right so in and I
figured that I could not break this
cycle that I was forever gonna be
trapped in this self defense mode when
under duress and that's when I was ready
to give up I read Michael Pollan's book
and I said I got to try these mushrooms
because apparently they do a pretty good
job so that's where I went into the
ceremony with a friend I'd had my five
gram journey you know closed the door
behind me I locked it and I said I'm
coming out when I'm done with processing
these five grams and it was a pretty
tremendous journey I felt that default
mode Network now I've come to understand
what happened and what happened was that
I was trapped in the cycle of neuron
firing that reacted just reacted and I
couldn't overcome it because it was just
too built into my network system neural
network system so so then that's when I
started searching for community and
found this very very strong community of
psychedelic community that their area
that included doctors nurses therapists
scientists botanists and I said wow what
the hell is this and where have you been
all my life right and so then we had a
meeting we all sat down at a table and
started just introducing ourselves as I
introduced myself I said I used to work
in government I worked in the Oakland
City Council my job was to get
legislation passed so if you all want to
pass something I'm happy to help and at
the very end dr. Gary Cohen oh who was
there with us said I think we should
pass a resolution and everyone else
agreed and so that's sort of what
started it on rolling so from there that
was December of 2018 and then by January
and February we wrote the resolution by
March we're meeting with council members
by April we have a sponsor by May were
at Public Safety and by June we passed
it unanimously and now the rest is six
once yeah six months Wow
and the resolution teach us about the
resolution so the resolution I think is
a beautiful resolution one year ago
passed so one year on the 20th of
October it will be one year yeah so the
resolution is beautiful it's so simple
it simply says in company in multiple
we're asses and therefore be it resolved
that our relationship to entheogenic
plants and fungi should be the same as
our relationship to Tomatoes
the same as our relationship to an
orange orange tree two herbs we want to
grow in our garden that there is nothing
fundamentally different between our
religions there should not be anything
fundamentally different than our
relationship to entheogenic plants and
fungi consciousness healing plants and
an orange that it's decriminalized
there's no controls on how much you grow
I can share it with friends and if I
choose to create a factory to take my
oranges and make orange juice now I plug
into pre-existing regulatory systems
that are already in place we don't have
to reinvent the wheel
so our resolution doesn't go that far it
simply says if you're going to grow it
for personally use to share and to enjoy
without the process of commodification
that is for sale or commercial sales or
commercial cultivation that there's no
constraints no controls no government
interference between that relationship
so and we think that's the way it should
be on planet earth wow what a
progressive so simple though isn't it it
is oh yeah I love the analogy to our
relationship with tomatoes or an orange
tree I love that that was really
eloquently written that with Indian
agent with antigens and with fungi shall
be similarly treated and that's very
elegant I like that the only reason not
to do it is fear and that's the only
argument we've ever heard against this
from people is what if somebody does
this what if a child gets a hold of it
what if and but then you you go to the
next step what if a child eats these
wall what if a child decides to cross
the street with a bus coming right
there's a certain there's certain things
that we as parents as adults are
supposed to help guide children through
including don't give them don't powerful
mushrooms
nevertheless poisonous deadly mushrooms
are not illegal so if we're gonna say
why you know what if a child eats these
what if a child eats those but we don't
seem to have the impetus to make those
illegal so then what does I liked how
you guys said when at the next level it
would be a a plugging into the existing
regulatory framework if someone was to
go beyond just going for their own
consciousness healing using entheogens
and fungi but how about then for you
know purposes in the last year like what
have you seen happen from that like what
has come up like what have people been
doing just like you know having antigens
B do criminal Ike mmm-hmm well currently
we still have the state and federal laws
in place which we're working on
hopefully changing soon and this is City
of the City of Oakland yeah so Ben if
you're in just the city yeah it's only
the local police and local prosecutors
that will not take any action or
prosecute against anyone with those
materials plant materials whatever but a
federal government federal officials
seeing somebody using them yes it's
still federally illegal it's still
illegal at the state level so that is
our next kind of ground to go after and
really our goal at the end of the day
would be to get all plants and fungi
removed from Schedule one because if you
think about it there's no way to get
them removed by testing because you test
compounds individual compounds you might
test psilocybin but a mushroom is not
psilocybin a mushroom there's many
different compounds so plants and fungi
never should have been put on Schedule
one because you can't test them off
schedule one so I think we may consider
broader action towards the federal
government that seeks to remove all
plants and fungi from Schedule one as
well as looking at how folks might
engage in a relationship with plants and
form
in a sacred ceremonial sacramental way
that that is protected under church
freedom of religion hmm
interesting so my inalienable rights for
my spiritual ascension technologies of
plants and fungi yes if you approach it
as a sacrament for personal religious
healing purposes it should not be
infringed upon by the government it's
such a beautiful expression of
consciousness right now because it's
like indigenous people have for the
longest time just been living with the
land and with each other and with these
plants fungi and then yeah government
has helped of course people organize
themselves into states and countries and
they opine on that for a while thank you
yes there are beautiful things that come
from government there are beautiful
things that come from capitalism they
are technologies and we embrace these
technologies because they help us to do
wonderful things but we should also be
open and aware that as we're evolving as
human beings as human societies there
are cost to these as well that we have
to now clean up right and we're seeing
that with climate change so we have to
recognize that while capitalism is good
it also has impacts so how do we begin
to transform that we don't have to throw
it away we just transform it to perfuse
aversion through that scope the code
updates yeah thank you yeah yeah yeah
damn there's some yeah there's some
archaic coats with plant and fungi yeah
that so it's doesn't really serious
because those have a lot to do with the
consciousness ascension and healing
which are paramount to having a
well-functioning self family
civilization at large yeah yeah one
might speculate that when these plants
and fungi were being co-evolved with
humans and we were using them to bring
peace into our own villages there were
other times perhaps we use them to
understand our enemy better but
certainly we use them to help advance
our own consciousness to live as a
community also to raise our awareness to
see trends to understand patterns and in
the ecosystems we were elevating our
consciousness with these plans so it's
very interesting that here we are now as
a species trying to figure out how we
survive ourselves and and these plants
are there as gifts to help guide us so
let's talk on on what what has happened
in terms of like business so when a city
does you know make these incremental
steps like you listed and then is able
to do something like decriminalize
psilocybin or fungi and entheogens what
what is able to transpire afterward for
for people you know this more may be
freedom with the feeling like they're
more free to engage with those in the
agents which is really beautiful
innocence and fungi but um also does it
seem like there is you know has in the
last year has there been businesses that
have emerged those look like yeah not
not so much yet because of the state and
federal restrictions they can't they
can't even incorporate this you can't
just say I'm wrong yeah because they
plugged into the same regulatory
framework that's right again and
yeah yeah so what we're looking at in
terms of the evolution at the local
level and which is actually where we'd
really like to put our energy as
decriminalizing the world if it grows to
that is how do we support the local
emergence of their own relationship with
these plants and fungi okay right
growing he'll grow gather gift grow
gather gift so helping people grow their
own helping people gift gather and gift
to to friends yeah interesting to gather
because uh it's a it's a naturally
growing phenomena so you can gather
rather than even have to grow
specifically in New York right well I
safely gather yeah and in that really
all that saying is in you know in East
Oakland we have a beautiful nursery that
is run by formerly incarcerated
individuals who do the work and then
they sell the plants well what a
beautiful thing if they could grow
mushrooms or grow banisteriopsis caapi
and Jack Runa for ayahuasca and they
could share this in a responsible we're
share this medicine with other people in
their own community and and help each
other heal that way so it's a healing
relationship you establish and that will
happen at the local level and we're
pretty sophisticated enough to know that
on top of that there will be many once
especially once this becomes state and
federally legal there's gonna be a whole
lot of commodification that happens so
that's that's not our agenda you want to
do that that's up to them but ours is
really to help build community around
these plants and fungi yes yes having a
direct relationship with them and they
can these communities that are
interested in
the antigen and fungi process of
bringing them into the communities the
decriminalization of them do you have a
protocols frameworks that they just
download how do they oh yeah yeah so we
actually do have thank you for using
word framework we actually have what's
called the Oakland framework for
entheogenic use antigenic planting fungi
use and it's a seven eight page document
we created at the request of City
Council they said one of the council
members Lauren Taylor actually asked us
to create some protocols to ensure the
protection of people in his community
because it's largely African American
community they don't have a lot of
experience in that community with
antigenic plant fungi use and so he
wanted us to bring the information that
we could gather forward to make
available to not only his community but
communities throughout the US who will
be new to this arena so we consulted
with doctors therapists nurses
psychiatrists longtime facilitators
without initials next to their names and
we created a set of seven page Oakland
framework for entheogenic plant and
fungi use and it goes everywhere from
preparation to micro dosing as a good
way to start all the way to reciprocity
when you've gone through the entire
process of self-healing the last piece
of that is reciprocity yeah that's so
cool okay so then now able to yet be
downloaded and use this framework and
hopefully to like you said each
community has will have its own unique
relationship with entheogens and fungi
and they'll get to decide how to
properly vet to be criminalized and what
do so then it seems like it could then
maybe not yet businesses but you can
maybe set up a meet-up and all go hang
out in the park and you know and yeah go
through conscious healing and ascension
together yeah yeah and what it has
enabled facilitators to be if
facilitators for those who don't know is
just people who are well trained and
helping people go through the journey so
it enables the entheogenic psychotherapy
sessions so healers and psychotherapists
can then work with these infusions and
fungi what they have a certification for
as a as a therapist with a capital T
then they're still not allowed because
that is a I believe a certification
granted to them by a government body
that is not local I believe it's state
but then non-capital T go that's right
certified yeah yeah that's right you
know people who have been doing this for
a long time can feel safer in providing
ceremony in their community and help
them facilitate that experience right
ceremony can in the community and then
also maybe making it based on a gift
base like you said through their last
chance or oh gathered yeah yeah yeah
very cool how do we ensure that people
like the indigenous that you were with
in Ecuador right that they and other
people that may not be reaping the great
fruits of such emerging markets how do
we ensure that these fruits become
democratized and distributed well so the
fruits buy the fruits do you mean the
actual materials or do you mean the
fruits of their labor and providing
knowledge right because intellectual
property these good Undead always have
some very deep historical intellectual
property that they're carrying around
with them and do deserve to be
compensated for their service and so how
do we do that we pay for their services
directly so if they fly up to the u.s.
to give a training they should be
compensated for their time and we should
appreciate what they bring to the table
and that's happening already the
materials themselves think we're a
little cautious about moving too fast to
commodify the actual materials at this
point in time at least from our
perspective we'd rather compensate the
individuals we'll bring the service word
and in terms of how we democratize the
materials themselves this is one of our
big concerns as decriminalized nature we
saw what happened in cannabis I was
directly involved in the cannabis
industry involved in a business in the
cannabis industry and the extent of
Greene that sort of prevailed in in
post-prom 64 and I saw it directly where
people were speculating once big capital
came in that it just became about
assembling as many different
dispensaries as you could it became less
about the medicinal and healing value of
cannabis it became more about how we can
commodify that whole thing and then
there were a lot of people who were
pushed out of it a lot of
african-american people who were
involved in the industry were suddenly
pushed out because they couldn't afford
to go through the regulatory process or
to get a permit and build out for a
million dollars plus their manufacturing
or their cultivation facility so a lot
of people got pushed out through that
process and the downside additional
downside is they were restricted on how
many plants they could grow so what
we're saying is do whatever you want to
do with commodification with
corporatization with clinical studies
just don't set any limit on what
people can grow because then you're
allowing people to have a relationship
the same kind of relationship I can have
with tomatoes with lemons with oranges
and if people would prefer to go to the
store and buy something off the shelf
that's produced then let them but if
they want to grow their own mushrooms or
create their own ayahuasca or their own
DMT then they should have that right and
so that's how we democratize it is we
allow people to retain that direct just
like Tomatoes find the right access and
tell the distribution of right then then
there's different frameworks that have
to well know forever forever they should
have it's like tomatoes we can still go
get tomato sauce or buy canned tomatoes
but I can also grow my own but then if
you grow for a million people then there
needs to be some sort of check I know
what we're suggesting is that people get
taught how to grow their own oh if they
so choose that in every community okay
we have taught how to yeah grow grow
their own mushrooms for example if they
want to right if they want to learn how
to grow their own there's people there
to teach them and then they can give to
their neighbor because then it's safe
they can that's right
yeah and then doesn't need to go through
a regulatory check because they already
learned how to grow but yeah and their
gifting it yeah you with Tomatoes as
long as yeah as long as they're grown
right yeah or that the yeah eggs are you
know well you can go tomatoes and spray
a bunch of pesticide all over it so
there's that too yeah but we don't we
don't regulate you from doing that yeah
we there's a certain level of trust
trust yeah and so we're saying the same
rules onto mushrooms with that same
level of trust that's right okay because
humans aren't is stupid sometimes as we
make them out to be yeah yeah it's a
nice fiction so that we can have greater
control at the higher levels of
government but and I'm not a libertarian
so this is not coming from a libertarian
speak it's just true right
Michael Pollan had a mushroom journey a
mushroom journey that he was spoke about
in the book and by the way I enjoyed it
very much and then he had several other
journeys and then when they asked him
are you okay with the way
decriminalization is rolling out he said
I'm concerned about safety so he's
concerned about others safety but not
but he's confident in his own abilities
to have safety protocols right so
there's a certain other Ness to that
we're saying is be okay that everybody
can make the same decisions is that you
can that you can that's right
everybody's just as smart smart yeah we
know how to survive as human beings
generally speaking yeah so we don't need
to have the treating whoa that's such a
cool way to put it yeah I wonder where
else that can be applied with all of the
oversight top-down oversight that's
happening a good question
yeah although generally we don't have
the same level of fear and anxiety that
we do over things like drugs right or
things like cannabis or things that
impact our consciousness or where the
government seems to have drawn a line in
1970 with Nixon was on things that
impact our consciousness even things
like deadly mushrooms poisonous
mushrooms
we're seem to be okay with those it's
just things that impact our
consciousness yes we seem to have
anxiety about as a government of the
people
I have one last question that we like
asking on a show what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
life
this
the alternatives pretty bleak kind of
lonely Carly and journeys been
fascinating and thank you for all your
incredible work thank you thank you
thank you yeah thank you [ __ ] you have
me on thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it love to hear your
thoughts on the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
check out the links to Carlos's work
also check out the links to the
decriminalised organizations around the
world do you believe in support a new
West summit where we're at right now
support simulation our show you can find
all our links in the bio below and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dream since the world do we love
you very much thanks for tuning in and
we'll see you soon
oh my gosh that was so great big yeah
thank you thank you
[Music]